okay so the new trailer for Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 is now out and
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down the Easter eggs hidden
details and also giving our theories on
what could be happening with the plot
we've got a lot to cover with the Super
Bowl but massively appreciate it if you
smash the Thumbs Up Button And subscribe
to stay up to date with all our
breakdowns on the Guardians final ride
if you're new here I'm Paul and we'll
also be going over whether it left a
Star-Lord or starboard you've turned the
video off haven't you but if you're
still here let's get another breakdown
I'm gonna tell you something
[Music]
[Applause]
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it now as always
James gonna pick the perfect song to
accompany the trailer and in the back in
here since you've been gone by rainbow
this is very much about someone who lost
love and the hyper focused on the
breakup of it it contains lyrics like I
get the same old dreams same time every
night fall to the ground and I wake up
so get out of bed put on my shoes and in
my head thoughts fly back to the breakup
these full walls are closing in look at
the fix you put me in this is of course
representing Peter who's been on a big
Journey since losing his Gamora in
Infinity War the person in the song is
having a complete mental breakdown and
they're basically begging that person to
get back with him which is what we see
quill doing very much in this opening we
catch him down on his luck in a bar and
over the top we can hear him speaking to
Gamora this bar is the place we caught
him in in the holiday special and like
we saw in that he slumped over he's
having a bad time now in that scene
Peter was drowning his Sorrows by
himself reminiscing of the love he lost
in his green-faced girl oh that's not
racist he's got one bottle tipped over
because he fully drank it and another
stood up with a porous sticking at the
top not sure what the brand is but it's
because it's got that thing on the top
I'm guessing he's grabbed it right off
the back of the bar we could do a shot
of him in the blue and red costume and
these are what the group ended up
wearing throughout the trailer back in
Avengers end game Rocket had one and
he's now likely made some for the rest
of the group The Balloon red uniform is
what they've done in the comics and it's
finally bring everything full circle for
their final film together now we next
see him shooting along a corridor in
what's very reminiscent of the prison
escape in that first movie I went back
and double checked and this is a new
scene for the film as Star-Lord doesn't
have a jumpsuit on now speaking of
jumpsuits we then cut to him and Gamora
wearing orange ones on the ship this is
a new ship it's not the Benetar the
Milano as one was destroyed
um but yeah this is the one that we also
saw in the holiday special over the top
we could have seen in the elevator and
see Peter explaining to Gamora what's
happened since she'd be gone I'm
guessing this scene on the ship takes
place after they've escaped the prison
which we see later on in the teaser this
is definitely overseen by the high
evolutionary as we can catch one of his
staff members in a white coat and later
on we catch Peter jumping out the vessel
on one he is however wearing his uniform
there so they might get them back and
then bring the whole thing down now in
the elevator we also catch some weird
lights that have been fused with flesh a
high evolutionary is combining all kinds
of creatures and machines in order to
create a perfect Society rocket is of
course lots of wires sticking out of his
back he's got metallic parts to him and
later on we see these experiments being
carried out the high evolutionary wants
to create a perfect Society but they
never will because they're all basically
the toys from Sid's room now in case you
don't know in the comic sees a character
called Herbert weinam who was born in
Manchester money in the building anyway
after debuting in the Mighty Thor issue
133 Herbert started to pick up the work
of Nathaniel Essex aka Mr the Sinister
he was fascinated with the character and
all his genetic experiments and he even
tried to replicate them himself by
building a genetic accelerator this
apparently sped up the evolutionary
process and it allowed him to basically
take creatures in a completely new
Direction now over the years the High
evolutionaries created several messed up
creatures including half dalmatian half
chimps and so on and so forth chimp dogs
if you've seen CatDog then you you'll
know what's happened there and though in
the comics he had a number of failures
it looks like he's cracked the formula
for the film we of course see the city
that looks like it's based on New York
and though there are people saying they
think this is planet Earth I actually
think it's a recreation of it a high
evolutionary was of course from Earth
and thus I think he's recreated the
planet and basically put his own people
in to build the perfect Society it also
seems like he's trying to get Rocket
back or potentially Rockets just like we
need if I need to find my crate and kick
the crap out of him now interestingly
the The Saga itself looks like it it's
got lots of different animals in it that
have been experimented on firstly we
have Cosmo who appeared in the recent
holiday special and they're going to be
making a return now being voiced by
Maria bakalova she I think she was in
that as well and she's back all over
this one
now she has teleconnect powers and due
to her ability to talk I'm guessing that
something happened there with the high
evolutionary might not be might be the
Soviets who did all that but yeah with
with considering that when we think
about the themes of the movie Cosmo is
going to be using a universal translated
to talk to the group and this is how we
can understand what the dog's saying
also worth pointing out that this
version of Gamora is a bit more Rough
and Ready than the one we saw in the MCU
and you can tell because her hair is not
as perfect as it used to be that's a
very good sign that she's been about the
block a bit I'll not talk to her
character in that kind of manner um but
yeah it's just a nice little touch from
the makeup Department the show she's a
slightly more I don't know ferocious
version of the character Gamora is of
course known as the deadliest woman in
the whole galaxy that's her nickname
officially
um yeah and we've never really seen that
side of her whereas it's clear here that
they're bringing it out we know that a
version of the first trailer was shown
at sdcc or or d23 one of those events
and that it had her leading the ravages
so that's kind of why she's taking on
this appearance she's not really
interested in love and I actually think
the movie is going to end with Peter
realizing that he can't win the person
back and that she's gone forever he's
desperate to have her back and I believe
the films are actually going to end with
him realizing that his Gamora is gone
and that no matter who he tries to
replace them with that the person he
lost is is now dead spoiler alert
I think the movie's gonna culminate with
Gamora and nebula going off into the
Galaxy by themselves and Peter will
return back to Earth though he has been
back there a couple of times he very
much never returned to the planet
because that's where he had the trauma
of losing his mother therefore I think
he's gonna go back reunite with a family
that he left behind in the first film
and then that'll be the culmination of
his whole Arc Gamora this isn't really
her and yeah I think she's gonna go off
and do something else whilst he returns
back home very very down ending very
depressing and but yeah I I do think
that death in the MCU needs to get its
consequences back at the moment it just
feels like he can bring anyone across
from the Multiverse and there's not this
impact that you're actually losing the
characters therefore I think for one to
come back and for it still to be messed
up and not the happy ending I think that
would really add some mistakes to the
entire thing going forward
can't save all dreams
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
didn't want to make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
now from here we get the Marvel Studios
logo and this is done to look like the
type deck that exists inside Peter's
ship it has that wooden grainy feel to
it and the stripes on the logo itself
are of course reminiscent of the first
two awesome mixes now from here we could
do a shot of the ship looking at a
planet I'm guessing that this is the
recreation of Earth or it might be Earth
itself but yeah to me something seems
off about it judging by Peter's reaction
now this could also be him seeing Gamora
for the first time as they are in a
coral at this point and it's very much
him just looking like what the hell's
going on as I mentioned earlier Gamora
is the leader of the ravages at this
point and this could be them coming
across the character and and realizing
all that she's been up to now next week
I do an experimentation chamber with the
high evolutionary you can see the back
of his head and notice that he has hair
here so I'm guessing that this is an
earlier scene from the movie in which we
discover Rocket's origin it's important
to bear in mind that the high
evolutionary also experiments on himself
and tries to make himself perfect which
is why there's versions where he looks
like uh RoboCop with the mask off you
know that he's got that stretch skin
that goes over the back of a machine
head and then normal hair looking like a
normal guy now we then cut to the
Guardians traveling through a hex point
and these are of course used throughout
the Galaxy to get from one point to
another very very quickly now clearly
located the high evolutionary ship and
later on we see a more sort of fleshy
Hellraiser version that's covered in
skin and hairs and stuff now amongst
this is Rocket's origin and I don't
think this was in the first trailer but
you can see other raccoon tails sticking
out in the cage Han is going towards it
and he looks very terrified about what's
about to happen which we actually see
playing out in a very gruesome scene a
high evolutionary stanza looking over
him and we can catch on the right two of
his servants there's tubes coming out of
rocket and we of course now that he has
ports for these on his back which these
all connected up to the positioning of
this also reminds me a lot of the
Vitruvian Man by Leonardo da Vinci but
let me know if that's a reach a scalpel
is used to get to serial number and I
might be looking too in depth on this
but it reminded me a lot of imagery from
the Holocaust every time I bring it up
someone's like oh you can't use this
stuff to to talk about comic book movies
but the way the numbers are kind of
crudely drawn on and the fact that it's
a Serial it does bring up imagery of
that which possibly I'm too close to and
but I do kind of see it whenever I see
this image Jewish people are of course
experimented on during that time and
there's several horror stories involving
Joseph Mengele which I don't want to get
into we'll keep the video light-hearted
and it could cut to Groot now next we
catch a nebula walking along and her arm
turns into a sword in the elevator scene
from earlier if you look at her arm you
can tell it seems very different to what
she normally has and it now looks like
it's able to morph and change now from
here we could do a shot that was shown
in the first trailer and it has the
Guardians jumping out of the high
evolutionary ship which looks very sort
of messed up in Hell existence have you
ever seen that movie it reminds me a lot
of that flesh is combined with machine
in and it's a very unique looking vessel
that definitely will bring up horrifying
images now when the first tease are
dropped a lot of people are saying this
looks like it's based on Among Us
however James can has cleared that up
and said the suits are actually based on
2001 A Space Odyssey now at this point
we catch them walking past the high
evolutionary who's holding his fingers
up to say wait one moment it looks like
he's almost a receptionist and I'm
guessing that this is early on in the
film in which they come across the
character it seems like they're having a
more cordial meeting here and then
they'll likely be captured and put into
the jumpsuits which will then take them
to the prison I want you all to know
that I'm grateful to fight beside my
friends
incinerate them
foreign
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
nadraxson says how grateful he is to be
able to fight with his friends and this
very much sounds like the final farewell
now from here we go to someone traveling
along a walkway we can't tell who this
is as they're in a suit with mechanical
arms and it seems like they're making
their way towards a ship core along the
side there's beaming hexagons that open
up and these all appear to have heat or
some kind of cosmic energy in them
reminding me a lot of the microwave
scene in Metal Gear Solid 4 in which
Solid Snake crawls along and I actually
think this might be Drax sacrificing
himself I can imagine going out almost
like Spock and giving that final speech
before heading in to blow up the ship
that's just my theory it might not be
right it's a theory if you will and but
yeah I'm kind of tying these two moments
together due to how they're placed in
the trailer the high evolutionary also
says incinerate them which is sort of
language that you'd expect someone to
use when they talk about burning samples
clearly once the guardian's taken out
and he's using their scientific term to
talk about getting rid of their bodies
might be rich now at this point we catch
craglin holding up yondu's Arrow
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 and with
them practicing using it and I'm
guessing that he's now using it to
protect nowhere we know that Adam
Warlock will be attacking this area in
the film and I'm guessing that this is
going on during his Ambush and kraglan's
just like I must Master the arrow and
use it to defend my people now from here
we go to Adam Warlock flying through
that town in the first trailer he's
completely destroying everything as he
passes through his power levels
unmatched and this is a guy that's
completely off the leash According to
some of the rumors around the film he's
going to be very much like a baby not
fully grasping his powers and these
god-like abilities will make him a very
destructive force I think the film is
very much going to be about the
Guardians being like whoa calm down mate
we've all had a drink don't fly through
the town destroying it and they're gonna
Reign him in and get him to join their
side however he will be an adversary at
first and this is why we see him
clashing with the Guardians in the
trailer now he also put the teaser in
0.25 speed like my man the Canadian art
show it's that guy really nice guy and
we can see Gamora running along carrying
rocket in her arms he's possibly been
beaten up badly at this point and it
could even tease out what happens in the
film so you get to put a death store the
Guardians might be like we need to find
the guy who made him so that he can
bring him back to full health that would
set them on a course with a high
evolutionary they'd find out how bad he
is and also discover rocket Sergeant's
story along the way anyway from here we
get to nowhere and see Groot stomping
down on Adam Warlock I'm guessing that
he attacks the Guardians at these two
places which includes the city and also
their home here next we see rocket
laughing and also Lila this character
was teased at in the first movie when he
was taken to the prison and in case you
don't know Lila's very much Rocket's
girlfriend you ought to know she's not a
whole
and she was also experimented on by the
high evolutionary which is why they're
crossing paths with her also I have a
call at the moment so the thumbs up is
much we appreciated and we sent the kids
to Nursery about three months ago and
since then I've had a constant mild cold
that sometimes plays up and makes my
voice sound like [__] I can catch it
Lila actually has a mechanical arm and
her real one was removed and then
replaced with this from here we get a
back-to-back shooting shot which is of
course a staple of the Guardians films
in the background you can catch the red
wall from the high evolutionaries
reception room and this is them very
much kicking ass and taking names or was
it asked I don't know we get some
Montage shots that include rocket
hugging Lila nebula celebrating on
nowhere and Peter and Gamora getting a
little close to each other there's a
little brown fairy character that you
see there and James Gunners actually
clarify that this is called blip expect
to see this on Funko Pops everywhere
your kids are gonna love it not mine
because they're really getting they're
getting no more presents for making me
ill all the time and it's possible that
this pulls from Captain Marvel issue 19
titled the accused does look similar to
an animal in that though it's a lot more
cute and furry and definitely designed
by Disney purposely to sell toys now
mimicking the prison escape again from
the first film we get a moment where
rocket stands on group childish shooting
this was of course what happened during
that escape and the boys are back in
town They're bringing back the good ones
this continued shot of them fighting on
the ship and a warlock going to tell
with Drax and is getting a prison
breakout scene that's very reminiscent
of the first film as they make their way
out we get a shot that was shown in the
first trailer and which tracks has
slumped over with a hole in his chest I
don't think he's done at this point
instead I think they're gonna Escape
come back and we'll get that emotional
send off in the third act that
definitely pulls from this character's
shot now we get more Montage shots such
as the high evolutionary floating along
the corridor he's doing a sort of
meditative stance beat a quill running
along his base and then the Guardians
standing together crying there's two
missing members here which appear in
rocket and I'm guessing that whilst is
going on let's see in which we see him
screaming whilst experiments are
happening plays out here finally we get
that shot on now where and you can see
that Drax is wearing the hoodie from the
holiday special Peter's being knocked
down he's getting carried along and it
looks like this is coming off the back
of the Adam Warlock attack whoever it
was that you were in love with it sounds
more like her her do not bring me into
though
knock it off what
we're noticed how black your eyes were
they were replaced by my father as a
method of torture he he picked a pretty
set
now you've got in the trailer with a
joke and we get solid fling with nebula
in front of Gamora don't do it we're
just there we've all done stupid stuff
like that and yeah don't bring up the
color of her black eyes saying that
though Karen Gillen yeah even if she was
a blue bald-headed woman I probably
would my wife's not watching this is you
anyway that's the video thanks for
sticking with me my voice is starting to
slightly improve us today as it warms up
um and I appreciate you bearing with all
the other cracking crackliness
um but yeah I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it make sure you comment
below and let me know I had fun with it
and this is probably you know Thai well
the Flash trailer we'll get into that
later on in the day but there were
moments in this that I really enjoyed
and I am excited to see the film just to
let you know we're also running a
competition giving away three copies of
the rocky 4K box set on the 15th of
March and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe and
notifications on and just just drop a
comment below letting us know your
thoughts if you want something else to
watch we've got a breakdown of The Last
of Us trailer on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thanks for singing to
the video I've been Paul and I see you
next time take care peace